sort of on a related note the problems
have obviously changed and you mentioned
earlier that your activism has changed I
wonder how have those changes impacted
your search for financial or
philanthropic donations either financial
or time treasure talent how do you go
about persuading people to contribute to
the cause you know one of the great
changes I've been thinking about this
recently because I'm trying to raise
money for something else is that in when
I began this I was asking people for
fifty dollars now I'm asking them for a
million and I'm not saying they answered
more quickly to either one of these
things but but the the ability of people
of means of great means to give hasn't
improved they've always been there
they've always had the possibility but
now I have access to them in ways I
don't think I had access to them as much
now as I as I did then as much then as I
did do now and so the amounts of money
we're talking about a much greater the
amounts of money required a much greater
because maxim and i walked the streets
of new york city nikon rich people's
doors asking them for help and we're
asking for more money than we would have
been doing had we been doing this 30 or
40 years ago I don't know it's because
we're bolder and more able to ask for
more or because we know that people are
asking have more and are therefore able
to to to give more but there is more
money in the world and the need for
money is as great if not greater than it
was before so I'm not sure how much has
changed except the amounts of money we
can ask for and the amounts of money we
can expect to give